[Music]
the eu or european union is a unique
political and economic union between 27
european countries for over 50 years the
eu has delivered economic prosperity
peace and stability helped raise living
standards for eu citizens and launched a
single european currency the euro
however
many european union citizens have a lot
of questions about how the eu works
especially young people
what exactly is a political and economic
union
an economic union is an agreement
between member states to allow goods
services money and workers to move over
borders freely a political union
involves member states working together
on important policies and political
issues in areas such as environment
health climate and justice
who came up with the idea of the eu and
why
the seeds for the european union were
sown way back in 1950 this was only five
years after the end of the second world
war
and european countries such as france
and germany that had fought bitterly
against each other were still suffering
the after effects of the social
financial and political devastation it
had caused
there was a determination to preserve
peace between european countries and
prevent another terrible war
on the 9th of may 1950 french foreign
minister robert schuman came up with the
unique proposal that european countries
come together and pool the production of
coal and steel
he wanted to create one big market
between countries for selling and buying
these two vital materials that were
essential resources needed to run a
successful economy
mr schuman's basic idea was that
countries that trade with each other
would be more likely to work together
politically and less likely to wage war
with one another
the idea worked and a year later in 1951
six countries belgium germany france
italy luxembourg and the netherlands
came together to create the european
coal and steel community
the ninth of may is now celebrated as
europe day across the eu in honor of
robert schumann who could be seen as the
founding father of the european
union so how then did the european coal
and steel community become the eu
the next major step forward towards
forming the european union came in 1957
with the signing of a very important
agreement the treaty of rome
the original six member countries of the
european coal and steel community
decided that working together worked
well and they wanted to do this in other
areas too and so was born the european
economic community with one of its core
aims being the creation of a common
market for goods and services
what is the common market for goods and
services and why was this such a big
step forward
the new common market meant citizens and
businesses in each of the six countries
could now trade freely with each other
across borders without any extra cost so
if you lived in france and you wanted to
buy a car from germany you could do so
without paying an extra tariff to bring
the car across the border into france
and vice versa
when did ireland and all the current
members join and when exactly did the
eec become the eu
ireland joined the eec in 1973 along
with denmark and the united kingdom
greece joined in 1981 spain and portugal
in 1986 then in 1993 with the treaty of
maastricht the eec changed its name and
the european union was officially
created
in 1995 eu membership increased when
austria finland and sweden joined
however it was 2004 that saw the eu
membership grow substantially 10 new
countries joined including eight newly
founded eastern european democratic
states that had previously been under
communist rule in 2007 bulgaria and
romania joined the eu and in 2013
croatia joined
as the united kingdom left the eu in
january 2020 there are now 27 member
states with a total population of nearly
450 million citizens
has there been any wars between member
states in the eu
since the creation of the eu there has
been no wars between member countries an
outstanding achievement that was
recognized when the eu won the nobel
peace prize in 2012
from peaceful beginnings the eu has
evolved into one of the most unique and
democratic bodies in the world
[Music]
ireland and irish politicians have been
at the heart of the european community
since 1973
and the impact of eu membership on our
nation has been more beneficial than
anyone could have imagined however
joining the eu was a long process for
ireland a lot of conditions had to be
met in fact irish politicians had spent
the previous 10 years trying
unsuccessfully to join
so why was it so important for ireland
to become a member
and why did we fight so hard to gain
membership
the 1950s and 60s were difficult times
for ireland with much unemployment and
immigration
agriculture was a big industry but most
of our exports were to the uk and our
economy relied heavily on this
our politicians understood that joining
the eec would give us access to a wider
and more competitive european market and
lessen ireland's economic dependence on
the uk
following a referendum in which 83 of
voters were in favor we joined the eec
in 1973.
so it's been really good for the irish
export industry and that is good news
for our economy however how has eu
membership helped ordinary irish people
one of the biggest benefits of being an
eu citizen is the freedom to travel
freely to live holiday study or work in
any european union country this freedom
of movement means irish citizens can
greatly increase their job prospects
improve their language skills and
experience other cultures the erasmus
plus program gives irish students and
apprentices the invaluable opportunity
to study or do a work placement in
another eu country
it also allows teachers youth workers
and volunteers gain professional
experience abroad
so if i want to travel to other member
states can i use the same euro that i
use here in ireland to buy things
most countries that are part of the
european union use the same currency
this currency is called a euro and it
can be used to pay for goods and
services when traveling in any one of
the 19 countries in the eurozone this
makes it much easier for irish people to
compare prices when traveling
it's also because of the eu that mobile
phone roaming charges have been
abolished and that air travel is cheaper
safer and open to more people than ever
before
should you become unwell whilst
traveling within the eu the free
european health insurance card helps you
access medical care so don't leave home
without it
how does the eu help with irish
consumers when they want to buy goods or
services from another eu country
one of the eu's greatest achievements is
the single market
it treats the eu as one shopping
territory without any internal borders
between eu countries and a few neighbor
countries when it comes to the free
movement of most goods and services
in fact thanks to the single market
irish consumers can now buy goods and
order services right across the eu and
their purchases are protected under eu
consumer law
i believe in equal rights for all
what has the eu done to improve the
rights of irish women
the eu is the driving force behind laws
that have improved equal treatment
between women and men when applying for
a job and when at work eu law also
protects the rights of pregnant workers
breastfeeding mothers and the rights to
maternity and paternal leave
the eu believes in equal rights for all
and protects people against
discrimination in the workplace based on
sexual orientation age disability
religion and belief
how
is
the european union helped the irish
language
the european union uses the motto united
in diversity so even though people in
the eu may have different languages or
cultures the eu protects the right of
people to use their own language and so
the irish language has been recognized
as an official language of the european
union
and what about day-to-day life has being
in the eu made it easier to live in
urbans
eu support and funding has had a hugely
positive effect on the development of
ireland
it has been used to transform ireland's
infrastructure from roads to railings to
ports eu funding has helped irish
farmers and rural ireland it has
financed training and employment
programs as well as provide support for
disadvantaged and vulnerable communities
it has helped to promote peace and
reconciliation in northern ireland and
the border regions and stood by ireland
throughout the brexit negotiation the eu
has helped to fund everything from
tourist attractions to town centres to
local projects that have helped save or
rejuvenate communities across the
country
[Music]
joining the eu has done a lot for
ireland in the past but ireland faces
future challenges due to brexit and the
covert 19 pandemic
how will the eu help
the kovat 19 pandemic has had a huge
impact globally but the eu is determined
that the future for irish and other
european students remains bright
education and training is set to benefit
hugely from the eu's massive 750 billion
covent recovery fund
designed to help member states face and
deal with all the different challenges
that the covert 19 pandemic has created
in the battle against coronavirus the eu
worked hard to accelerate the research
and development of safe and effective
vaccines and the 5 billion euro brexit
adjustment reserve is set to help
countries like ireland who will be
financially affected because of brexit i
live in the countryside a farming is
very important to my community what will
the eu do to help irish farmers the eu
is fully committed to protecting the
environment ensuring a safe and secure
food supply and supporting farmers
the aim of the common agricultural
policy or cap is to improve food quality
and animal welfare standards whilst also
keeping irish farmers competitive in a
rapidly changing industry by helping
them expand their farms upgrade
equipment and access training
fishing has always been important to our
island nation and the eu's common
fisheries policy will continue to help
support the interests of irish fishermen
fishing communities and consumers
i care very much about nature
and the effects of global warming on the
world and airland
what is the eu
doing about the climate emergency
climate change is the biggest challenge
facing this and future generations and
the eu is at the forefront of the battle
to tackle it
eu laws have already brought about great
improvements in ireland in areas such as
waste management and air quality
for example the eu law which allowed for
the recycling of electronic and
electrical appliances has seen thousands
of items going into managed irish
recycling systems instead of ending up
in landfill sites
the european green deal will see the
union become a world leader on climate
change by committing to make the eu the
world's first carbon neutral continent
by 2050
this means achieving net zero emissions
for eu countries as a whole
mainly by cutting emissions investing in
green and sustainable technologies and
jobs and protecting the natural
environment
growing up all i've ever known is a
digital world but a lot of people older
than me are still getting used to a tech
world
what is the eu doing to speed up that
change
a new digital economy is rising the
digital european program 2021 to 2027 is
the very first ever funding program
solely dedicated to supporting digital
transformation in the eu 8.2 billion
euro will be spent in areas such as
super computing artificial intelligence
cyber security and in helping every
company small or large high-tech or not
to take advantage of digital
opportunities and so in turn make life
easier better and faster for eu citizens
and businesses
how does the eu impact on the rest of
the world
with its digital program and green deal
the eu was leading the way in dealing
ambitiously with two of the biggest
challenges that the global community
faces the eu is proud to be the world's
biggest donor of overseas development
aid to poorer more vulnerable countries
and as a result of the eu being a global
economic superpower in worldwide trade
affairs irish exporters and consumers
benefit hugely by being a member of the
european union ireland has a bigger say
in big issues that affect both the eu
and global community
[Music]
so how exactly does the eu work
each of the 27 member countries of the
european union remains an independent
self-governing state
however
in certain areas member states delegate
or hand over some of their
decision-making powers to shared eu
institutions they have created
so if you member states make important
decisions about certain things
how do they do it and where are they
doing from
three key institutions in eu decision
making are the european commission the
council of the european union and the
european parliament
the european commission based in
brussels is responsible for the
day-to-day running of the eu it is
responsible for proposing policies and
new laws
and this is decided upon by a college of
27 commissioners one from each member
state
the european parliament approves the
president of the commission the current
president of the commission is ursula
van der line who is from germany and the
term of office is five years both for
the president and for the college of
commissioners
what responsibilities do individual
commissioners have and whose views do
they represent
commissioners do not represent their
countries instead they have a portfolio
of areas of responsibility given to them
by the commission president
in my case that's everything to do with
the financial system the stock market
and financial stability but i'm also
dealing with new things like digital
innovation in the financial area and
very importantly how we could get money
invested in the green recovery and i
think that's a hugely important issue
i'm from ireland but at the college i
represent all of europe not just ireland
how does a commissioner decide which two
laws to propose
so essentially the college of
commissioners draft legislation or
indeed change existing legislation but
we don't do it on our own we listen to
stakeholders those who have an interest
in that policy area and sometimes we ask
people to give us their views of what's
coming up
how can ordinary people have a say into
proposed or existing eu laws
citizens businesses and organizations
can get involved in europe's future
direction by sharing their views on new
eu laws or on how to improve existing
laws via public consultations process on
the commission website
you can log on and give your views on
specific issues that are open for public
consultations and a very important
public consultation underway at the
moment is the conference on the future
of europe we really would welcome young
people's views as to how the european
union should look in the future
and how does a policy proposal become an
actual eu law
once a policy proposal is approved by
the 27 commissioners it then moves
forward to the council of the european
union
and to the european parliament and both
those european institutions then decide
whether it will become a law or not
the council of the european union is
made up of government ministers from the
different eu countries and depending on
the policy proposal you will see the
relevant ministers attending
the european parliament is made up of
705 members from the 27 eu member states
how often are members of the european
parliament elected
meps are directly elected by eu voters
every five years to promote the
interests of the 450 million citizens
the allocation of mep seats is based
purely on population size and the more
the country grows the more possibility
they'll be able to add meps in ireland
we have 13 in total
once a month we vote in what we call
plenary so voting sessions and they are
done in strasbourg in france the other
three weeks of the month we have
meetings in brussels in belgium
does the european parliament and the
council of the european union always
agree on new laws
when the council and the parliament
don't agree on legislation which is
actually quite a lot we have to meet up
and agree a compromise before a new law
is enacted negotiations begin each site
outlining the important issues for them
and it's about concentrating on the
issues that unite us rather than divide
us
once a law is adopted it is the role of
the european commission to ensure that
it is properly applied in all member
states
what role does our tea shop have to
european union the thieshok and other eu
member states leaders all form part of
what is known as the european council
it holds regular summit meetings during
the year to discuss the overall
political direction of the eu
you could say they need to discuss the
big picture
okay i'm beginning to understand how it
all works but are there any more eu
institutions other important eu
institutions include the european
central bank the main bank of the 19
eurozone countries
the european court of justice ensures
all eu laws are applied correctly and
the european court of auditors oversees
the proper management of eu money
all of the eu institutions exist to
ensure that the european union operates
in an open democratic and transparent
way and that citizens interests and
rights are protected
[Music]
what about working for the eu are there
many opportunities for young people
each year around 1 900 young eu
graduates are offered the chance to
apply to take part in one of the eu
trainee programs
opportunities are available in a variety
of eu institutions and in a wide range
of fields including competition law
human resources environmental policy
communication and many more
these are periods of time where you get
your foot in the door you get a sense of
what the eu does how it works and you'll
get a sense of what kind of job you
would like to do within the eu
institutions as well i'm based in
brussels my job involves
all sorts of communication my speciality
is social media so i get to research
what works and what doesn't work on
social media
so i started as a trainee in the
communication unit traineeships are
important because you
need people to explain things to you
it's also important for making friends
and
meeting people who are at the same stage
of life that you're at at the same stage
of career that you're at to find out
more visit epso dot europa dot eu
forward slash job opportunities forward
slash traineeships
aside from traineeships what other
long-term career prospects does the
european union offer
the eu institutions employ over 40 000
people mainly in the european union but
also in locations all around the world
there are so many different career
options within the eu institutions
anything from being a lawyer to being an
accountant working on human resources
for any eu civil servant we all have to
have two eu languages when we start off
but to stay within the eu institutions
you'd need to have three eu languages at
your disposal i would for example have
started off with irish english i french
and i brought german with me as well
one of the very interesting jobs that
are available to people with languages
is the job of being an interpreter
working as an eu interpreter here in
brussels is a really exciting job you're
right at the center of the action and
all the debate that goes on within the
european union and you really do get an
opportunity to see history in the making
here in the european institutions for
example politicians citizens and
officials can speak any one of the eu's
24 official languages interpreters
translate a message from one language to
another aloud and in real time so that
everybody can understand and follow
what's being said
i interpret from french german and irish
into english
you've also got a range of
administrative jobs and that can be
anything from making sure that policies
are put together and are implemented to
helping the politicians communicate
their policies as well
i'm a communications manager at
eurofound located in dublin and our role
is to provide knowledge and information
to eu policymakers and national
governments and social partners to help
them shape better policies for citizens
whether it's gender issues industrial
relations employment and bigger issues
like climate change
i work in a multicultural environment i
work with people from lots of different
countries and it's great to be part of
the european project but at the same
time as an irish person i get to live in
ireland diversity is also one of the
reasons that i love working in the
european commission you get people from
all over europe but also all over the
world and
you're never short of an interesting
conversation
so if i had any advice for young people
i'd say brush up on your languages as an
irish person native english speaker you
have a huge advantage but if you can arm
yourself with french with spanish or
another language i think so many more
doors will be open to you
on the 1st of january 2022 irish will
become a full official working language
of the eu institutions we need
translators we need interpreters we need
proofreaders and we need lawyer
linguists if you'd like to work for the
eu institutions in the future take a
look at our website eu ireland dot ie we
have a page there work for the eu which
gives you a sense of the different
career opportunities available and the
places where you could find information
as a young person who wants to find out
even more about the eu and get involved
what can i do
there are many dynamic and interesting
ways young irish people can get involved
including online and in-person
participation
for almost 50 years ireland has been an
active and valued member of the eu we
have benefited hugely from our
involvement and we've contributed to its
success
for this generation and generations to
come ireland's future is a european
future
i'm proud to be a member of the eu
family
it's a very big family
there are
450 million of us in 27 member countries
and as an eu citizen i can travel freely
to any of these countries
i can shop without any extra tariff or
cost
for goods and services from any one of
the member states
and thanks to eu laws both me
and me have the right to equal pay for
equal work
and every eu citizen can work freely
in any one of the 27 member countries
to find out more follow the european
commission representation in ireland on
twitter instagram and facebook